14h15 au centre aquatique de saint cyr
l'école la piste andy cabreira avis lie
dans la dernière heure de son record une
performance de six heures sans
interruption le franco cubain temps de
respirer le moins possible dans une cage
pour dénoncer le traitement des animaux
marins dans les eaux c'est quelque chose
de très très compliqué à gérer sur le
plan de
la respiration de la récupération la
gestion de l'effort donc c'est quelque
chose de très exigeant et qui nécessite
une très très bonne ou bonne
connaissance de soi une performance
qu'il accomplit sous les yeux d'une
dizaine de supporters déjà c'est très
impressionnant parce que tenir comme ça
le mental est sûrement très très fort
donc on est vraiment sous le charme fait
dans 10 c'est difficile
mais je pense qu'il a les capacités pour
y arriver
dix minutes avant la fin du record le
clan dandy cabreira est optimiste
très bien il est même en avance par
rapport à son entraînement il s'était
échauffé une première fois il y avait
ces six heures une première fois il est
très en avance par rapport à autant
qu'ils l'avaient fait précédemment
15h15 andy réussi officiellement son
record son temps de respiration et de 4
minutes et 12 secondes sur six heures
d'apnée il ya beaucoup de choses qui
bougent à vous pouvez vous mais un
goûter et le sel dans ce top donc sur la
spli c'est difficile mais moi c'est
totalement fini j'ai pas aux gains de
capacité pulmonaire donc j'ai joué avec
ma force de volonté
les cds garder mon mental j'ai dépensé 1
comme au président et à des cubes à fort
de france
le nageur espère également avoir réussi
son autre défi sensibiliser le grand
public sur la cause animale
tu me mets dans la peau d'un enfant qui
doivent vivre en liberté et nager 5 km
par jour
elle s'est nourrie à des poissons
vivants alors être tous la vie à
perpétuer impressionné simplement pour
les placer à décembre
c'est pas juste non je pense que les
messages et la l'histoire entre andy
cabreira villa et les records n'est
peut-être pas encore terminée le sportif
a déjà évoqué l'idée de replonger pour
de nouvelles performances à couper le
souffle